Academy thank you
trying to capture Dr Shirley's essence
pushed me to my my ends and um
which is a reflection of the person he
was and the life that he lived I thank
my partner Vigo
extraordinary working with you
Peter fairlea thank you for your
leadership and your guidance really
appreciate it love you Octavia Spencer
Chris Bowers my double
um I want to I want to dedicate this to
to my grandmother who has been in my my
ear my entire life
telling me that if at first I don't
succeed try try again
that I could do anything I put my mind
to
always always pushing me to to think
positively and I know that I would not
be here without her I think my wife and
my daughter Bari again thank you so much
[Applause]